but you you mentioned the convergence
thing
so the the whatever the thing associated
with the disease
shows up so let me explain convergence
yeah convergence is such a beautiful
concept
so you basically have these four genes
that are converging on calcium signaling
so that basically means that they are
acting each in their own way
but together in the same process
but now in every one of these loci you
have
many enhancers controlling each of those
genes
that's another type of convergence where
this regulation of seven different
enhancers
might all converge on this regulation of
that one gene
which then converges on calcium
signaling
and in each one of those enhancers you
might have multiple genetic variants
distributed across many different people
everyone
has their own different mutation but all
of these mutations are impacting that
enhancer and all of these enhancers are
impacting that gene
and all of these genes are impacting
this pathway and all these pathways are
acting the same tissue
and all these tissues are converging
together on the same biological process
of schizophrenia and
and you're saying the saving grace is
that that conversion seems to happen for
a lot of these diseases
for all of them basically that for every
single
disease that we've looked at we have
found an epigenomic enrichment
how do you do that you basically have
all of the genetic variants associated
with the disorder
and then you're asking for all of the
enhancers active in a particular tissue
for 540 disorders we've basically found
that indeed there is an enrichment that
basically means that
there is commonality and from the
commonality we can just
get insights so to to explain in
mathematical terms
we're basically building an empirical
prior
we're using a bayesian approach to
basically say great all of these
variants
are equally likely in a particular locus
to be important
so in a genetic locus you basically have
a dozen variants
that are co-inherited because the way
that inheritance works in the human
genome
is through all of these recombination
events
during meiosis you basically have
you know uh you you inherit maybe three
chromosome three for example in your in
your body it's inherited from four
different
parts one part comes from your dad
another part comes from your mom another
part comes from your dad another part
comes from your mom so basically
the way that it i'm sorry from your
mom's mom
so you basically have one copy that
comes from your dad and one copy that
comes from your mom
but that copy that you got from your mom
is a mixture
of her maternal and her paternal
chromosome
and the copy that you got from your dad
is a mixture of his maternal and his
paternal chromosome
so these break points that happen when
chromosomes are lighting up
and lining up are basically ensuring
through these crossover events they're
ensuring that every
uh child cell
during the process of meiosis where you
basically have
you know one spermatozoid that basically
couples with one oval
to basically create one egg to basically
create the zygote
you basically have half of your genome
that comes from that and half your
genome that comes from one
but in order to light up not line them
up you basically have these crossover
events
these crossover events are basically
leading to
co-inheritance of that entire block
coming from the your maternal
grandmother and that entire
block coming from your material grand
grandfather over many generations
these crossover events don't happen
randomly
there's a protein called prdm9 that
basically guides
the double-stranded breaks and then
leads to these crossovers
and that protein has a particular
preference to only a small number of hot
spots
of recombination which then lead to a
small number of
breaks between these co-inheritance
patterns so even though there are six
million variants there are six million
loci
there there's you know this variation is
inherited in blocks
and every one of these blocks has like
two dozen genetic variants that are all
associated
so in the case of fto it wasn't just one
variant
it was 89 common variants that were all
humongously associated with obesity
which ones of those is the important one
well if you look at only one locus you
have no idea
but if you look at many loci you
basically say
aha all of them are enriching
in the same epigenomic map
in that particular case it was
mesenchymal stem cells so these are the
progenitor cells
that give rise to your brown fat
and your white fat
you